[Musique]
c'est jeudi matin que la france se
réveillaient avec l'annoncé du décès de
bertrand kamel ce jeune candidat de
l'émission koh lanta qui disparaissaient
les suites d'un cancer foudroyant en en
effet appris la mort d'un des candidats
de l'aventuré qu'on est en train de
suivre en ce moment bertrand kamal à
seulement 31 ans le jeune homme a été
emporté en moins d'un an par la maladie
qui s'est déclaré après sa participation
au jeu d'aventuré koh lanta
voilà maintenant deux semaines que le
jeu est diffusée sur tf1 et que les
téléspectateurs ont fait la connaissance
de ce jeune sportif déterminer je
m'appelle bertrand kamel je suis
animateur chef de village en hôtel club
et je suis originaire de dijon
très vite suite l annonce de sa
disparition nombreux sont les
téléspectateurs qui se sont interrogés
sur la suite à donner à cette saison de
koh lanta déprogrammation montage
difficile de savoir quoi faire dans un
pareil cas du côté de la chaîne et
adventure line le producteur du jeu
pas question de changer la diffusion du
programme toutefois vendredi dernier
denis brogniart a enregistré un message
spécial diffusé en début de soirée pour
rendre hommage à bertrand kamel je ne
t'oublierai jamais nous ne t'oublierons
jamais et nous te dédions évidemment
cette saison de koh lanta
un hommage passer devant 5,1 millions de
téléspectateurs
alors disparition de bertrand kamel tf1
at-elle bien géré la situation
avec sa large ou père est avec nous pour
lui poser toutes vos questions et saison
et tf1 a bien géré la situation ou pas
merci alexia d'être là je suis très
peiné je le sais parce que vous avez
passé beaucoup de temps et que la
famille de bertrange bertrand kamel ce
week end
oui on était avec avec denis brogniart
et julien magne le producteur on était
samedi avec eux dans un moment
incroyablement émouvant
parce qu'il y avait deux familles qui se
réunissent et la famille de la maman qui
est chrétienne et la famille devenu papa
qui est marocain musulman et gg c'est
pour ça que je suis là c'est que c'est
incroyable l'amour et la tolérance qui
se dégager de ces deux familles parce
que bertrand a quand même été fait de
ces de ces deux cultures de ces deux
religions de ces deux pays et ce amiens
et son papa yannick sa maman sont l'ont
élevé avec une dose d'amour que j'ai
rarement vu et d'avoir été avec eux qui
était un moment très émouvant et très
intime
voilà moi je devais une communion qui
était incroyable et je trouve que c'est
un message d'amour et de tolérance
qu'ils portent
lui aussi est que je suis heureuse de
relayer ici alors on a on a eu des
impôts alors son cancer a été détecté
après l'aventuré bien sûr c'est ça a été
une terrible nouvelle
où on m'a dit qu'il s'était il s'était
un peu blessé pendant l'aventuré sa
sellerie oui s'est blessé dans
l'aventuré ou un truc assez bénin il a
et suite à koh lanta
il avait encore mal et à ce moment là il
est allé faire des examens et en fin de
compte ils ont décelé
c'était je crois le 17 avril
un cancer très agressif malheureusement
et donc voilà ça a été extrêmement
violent parce que ce savoir perdre en
quarts mais avec les l'expression même
de la joie de vivre mais vraiment enfin
moi je me rappelle les images de son
casting où il est arrivé il avait ce
look de baroudeur traits du toujours
sourire et d'un sourire
c'est vrai les et c'était incroyable et
il a il après ça a été vraiment fait ce
qu'il a vécu en terme de souffrance
il a été admirable est ce que moi je
l'avais régulièrement au téléphone il
arrivait encore à faire des pointes
d'humour alors je sais que c'était
c'était très violent
ça a été très rapide en plus ouais
c'était et 1 3 moi je moi je trouve que
tf1 personnellement bien fait le boulot
parce que je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez alexia mais c'est ce qu'on a ici
c'est ce qu'en pensaient les
téléspectateurs c'est que moi si j'avais
été de la famille bertrand car elle
j'aurais eu qu'une envie c'est de le
voir vivre cette aventure et parce que
je sais que la question s'est posée au
moment de couper bertron ans kamel au
montage de peut-être alors ça s'est pas
posée par dont la chorale je me permet
de m'exprimer là dessus déjà il faut
savoir que nous étions extrêmement peut
être au courant de la situation et de la
gravité de la maladie de bertrand kamel
il y avait deux personnes à tf1 et nous
étions trois dans l'équipe dont denis
être au courant ce qui fait que les
équipes ont monté le programme sans être
absolument au courant de la situation de
bertrand kamel et et donc il y avait 1 1
est ce qu est ce qui est remarquable
c'est que rien n'a été changé au montage
quand on a compris que ça devenait de
plus en plus graves
évidemment on était en lien avec la
famille et samir le papa a tout de suite
parlé à bertrand kamel et il lui a dit
mais qu'est ce que tu veux faire tout ça
et bertrand kamel et a été immédiatement
lui a dit c'est ma plus belle aventure
bien sûr
je veux la voir et je suis tellement
enfin pardon mais je suis tellement
heureuse qu'il ait vu les deux premiers
épisodes
c'est j'en parlais avec son père samedi
ils ont enfin c'est le moment
alors que voilà il venait de faire la
toilette chikhates ward de leur fils et
de regarder l'émission il avait
l'impression d'être avec lui et puis
notre écusson aventure et en plus il
reçoit le totem lors de cette émission
alors donc c'était voilà qui a fait
beaucoup réagir et qui nous a beaucoup
touchés pendant cet épisode de vendredi
il vient de remporter l'épreuve et
l'équipe de bertrand kamal avaient le
choix entre deux choses les allumettes
ou les pizzas et entre les deux je
crains que bertrand qui n'a pas du tout
regretté son choix regarde
il prend la responsabilité pour
l'ensemble de l'équipe de m'annoncer la
décision je parle de pidgeon à deux
pizzas d'une semaine alors pizza moi
c'est un bidouillage de saveur lien
c'est l'euphorie
pourquoi ce fait ces deux ans alors
qu'ils pensent que tf1 bien gérer pour
la pratique mans tous valérie bénaïm
ballon c'est pas il y a pas mis sa
pancarte mais ils atteindraient pendant
ce we
non mais savoir si la famille avait dit
on aimerait que au montage son rôle soit
réduit qu'est ce que vous auriez fait je
pense qu'on aurait évidemment parlé avec
la famille enfin on était en est
inconstant donc 6,6 alors on aura enfin
on n'aurait rien fait qu'il soit hires
entre eux ou contre contre la famille ou
bertrand
quand même parce qu'on est en lien je
cuis ça me fait rire cette séquence
qu'il apporte le sourire et c'est vrai
que lors du casting on lui avait dit
mais qu'est ce que vous allez apporter à
votre équipe et je le cite il va je vais
apporter de la folie prendre soin des
gens je suis un papa protecteur et c'est
incroyable parce que c'était la folie de
prendre la pizza on est d'accord je suis
quelqu'un de raids auraient pris le feu
bah oui et mais c'était ça sert que
c'est toujours la blague et l'humour
j pourquoi vous dis que ça a été mal
géré alors j'entends parfaitement ce que
dit alexia laroche joubert et et je
respecte c'est un drame épouvantable
mais moi j'ai ressenti en regardant cet
épisode un immense malaise parce que je
trouve que c'est très perturbant d'avoir
quelqu'un qui est décédé et je pense que
la bonne décision de la chaîne je le
redis aurait dû être d'annuler la saison
moi je vous dire pour moi la bonne
décision de la chaîne c'est d'écouter la
famille sy d'écouter la famille le choix
de bertrand kamel je suis désolé la
bonne décision de la chaîne de la
production
vous allez pas c'est pas d'écouter
gilles verdez mais vous me demandez mon
avis oui oui bien sûr mais c'est bien de
le donner et s'il avait été moi si
j'étais le premier à me poser la
question comme vous mais quand j'ai su
que la famille et bertrand gamme elle
voulait être diffusé et mine de rien je
trouve que ça fait du bien de le voir
vendredi soir et ses parents et ben là
pendant quelques semaines tous les
vendredis soirs eh ben ils vont avoir
l'impression d'être avec lui et je pense
que ça avait des moments compliqués à
vivre mais des moments dont ils vont
avoir besoin
donc je suis un peu désolé là tu vas y
je suis complètement inverse de ce que
tu dis toi moi j'ai regardé cette
émission je ne connais pas ce garçon
mais je le garde j'ai regardé toutes les
missions avec un sourire de maman sur le
visage j'avais j'étais heureuse pour lui
je riais avec lui je l aventure pour lui
j'imaginais ses parents et au contraire
moi j'ai pas du tout ressenti de malaise
j'étais comme jeu j'avais l'impression
qu'il faisait partie de ma famille que
je sais que je l'accompagnais une
dernière fois donc voila tu vois ce que
je veux dire et j'imaginais mois ses
parents heureux de voir leurs six bien
sûr tu parlais tout à l'heure à l'excès
a parlé de la toilette mortuaire etc
mais non pas dans ce set dernière image
mais au contraire une image solaire
souriante sur la lose j'ai oublié comme
ça enfin je te remercie parce que nous
on a énormément côtoya juin et il est
comme ça ça access et c'est un soleil ce
garçon alex s est ce que c'est vrai
l'impôt que le médecin lui aurait dit
pendant koh lanta il avait une douleur
il y aura c'est il faut vraiment que tu
ailles voir un médecin
s'il sait des tarifs dès que tu sors de
la voiture faut vraiment avoir un
médecin parce que certaines que tu es
aussi mal que ça en jeu alors
sincèrement j'étais pas vous savez c'est
qu'on finance est alors la relation
entre le médecin et la sensation croyais
je sais juste qu'il est allé voir un
médecin c'est ça qu'il avait glanées
dans blow est juste et que c'était
étonnant qu'il ait mal comme ça mais
maintenant je sais pas exactement ce
qu'ils veulent au regard yen il ya un
truc moi qui m'a dégoûté je vous dis
voilà suite à la mort de bertrand kamel
quelques internautes ont été très loin
avec certains candidats notamment les
candidats mathieu et dorian certains
internautes leurs proches de rigoler de
faire du sport sur install alors qu'il
devait être en 2 10 on a retrouvé les
stories pointé du doigt par les
internautes
voilà vous dirais que si vous comprenez
les critiques ou pas et c'est vrai que
voilà là on n'est pas là dedans dans la
polémique et c'est vrai que les gens
essaient de trouver encore des
polémiques partout regardez
non
oh
[Musique]
ils sont pas malheureux ces aventuriers
c'est plus de 6 des colombes
à votre avis c'est le plat de qui eh ben
voilà je suis pas une équipe non non ne
change pas une équipe qui gagne
[Musique]
bravo mon pote
l'équipe des bleuets est bien
représentée l'équipe des verts ale je
suis entré en jeu ramenait les oranje
allez c'est parti
épreuve va chercher la pierre alexia on
a vu il ya un instant si vous nous
rejoignez qui avait les polémiques
certaines personnes qui disaient que y
avait des candidats de koh lanta qui
rigolaient encore alors que on ya eu un
drame dans koh lanta chez qui rigolait
sur leurs réseaux sociaux si vous avez à
répondre à ça parce que ça c'était notre
petite crainte aussi et on s'est dit
voilà est-ce que les gens vont oser et
ils osent mine de rien s'attaquer à ça
aussi déjà je demande pendant une
période de deuil et perdre en bertrand
cas mais n'aurait pas supporté ce à
d'autant plus que là on voit par exemple
des images de loïc loïc c'est l'un des
derniers à avoir vu bertrand quand même
il est allé à l'hôpital
loïc était effondré nous on a envoyé un
communiqué le lendemain du décès de
bertrand kamel justement pour prévenir
un à un tous les aventuriers ils étaient
enfin c'est une vraie famille quoi c'est
vous voyez ce garçon il a apporté
tellement de bonheur à son équipe et au
reste des aventuriers que c'est pas
possible de tolérer ça vraiment c'est
une c'est une famille entière qui est en
deuil
merci en tout cas alexia productrice de
koh lanta dont koh lanta va continuer
comme ça et on aura des nouvelles en
fait on aura on verra bertrand kamel
tous les vendredis soirs et moi j'ai
hâte de voir polenta qui cartonne bravo
en tout cas alexia
[Applaudissements]